on this episode I go really fast this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and welcome to episode
43 of the askgaryvee show before I get
into the episode I just want to wish my
amazing wife Lizzy a happy 10th
anniversary I'm thrilled to get to this
milestone tomorrow is my 39th birthday I
will be going away with Lizzy for the
weekend so no show tomorrow so for the
question of the day please just wish me
a happy birthday just excited thank you
guys for this feels appropriate to say
thank you for watching the show I'm
enjoying it I'm enjoying it so much that
I have a very important meeting in four
minutes so we're gonna bang out two
quick questions on a condensed very
family celebration episode of the
askgaryvee show Mike asked
shark tank's Barbara Corcoran doesn't
invest in rich kids businesses how do
you feel about entrepreneurs from
privilege you know Babs from the shark
tank is a one of my favorite characters
I like calling Barbara Babs has just
been something I've been doing three
years Barbara long if you're watching
that's where it started wine industry
chatter you know look I was very much we
all have our prejudice and since I came
from a zero place I have for a long time
talked about the rich kid syndrome right
now I talked about the Ivy League if I
go to an Ivy League school I should be a
founder because succs wears a hoodie I'm
wearing a hoodie today's perfect timing
you know and so for a long time I've
really pushed against that and said
they're not hungry enough they're not
pushed enough look my kids are gonna be
rich kids and I think what I've learned
is I've gotten older as we all am 39
tomorrow and because of one or two very
special friends in my life right now
that grew up very wealthy but are hungry
and fiery and making stuff happen I
think it comes down to anything like a
business I talk about being a media I
just had an amazing meeting with
somebody and they're like this place is
so caring it's so good and I thought was
gonna get worse when we got the 400
versus 150 and I said look it stems for
the top like I actually give a crap and
I think that trickles through and that's
the same thing on this I when I meet
rich kids and see their pitches spend 45
out of the 50 minutes asking them about
how they were raised how their parents
the game the reason I think my rich kids
are gonna be okay is because if they act
too rich Kitty I'm gonna punch them
directly in their mouth right and what I
mean by that is not like literally
because I know some of you will freak
out with that though I may go there I'm
a little weird Eastern European but like
the truth is just I'm gonna humble them
I'm gonna I'm gonna hurt their feelings
I'm gonna make them cry I'm gonna tell
them how soft they are and so I think
that um I think that it comes down to
the parenting just like it comes down to
the CEO in a business everything's
trickles from the top just cuz you grew
up with a hundred million dollar kind of
trust doesn't mean that you don't have
the hunger and just because you grew up
with $30,000 in cash maybe your mom did
everything for you and took care of
everything for you it's how you were
raised what's the foundation you know
it's it's it's the cement my dad Wine
Library was built to be a 16th floor
building and everybody made fun of my
dad from an engineering standpoint he's
an old-school guy he just wants the
foundation to be strong and there's too
much steel and concrete in the basement
of wine library and that's kind of how I
think about this question what's the
foundation I'm not worried about the
optics the interior decorating it's the
foundation zebra studios ask how long
are you going to make us wait for the
heart to brain to wall a t-shirt
mentioned in episode 41 zebra not too
long and the links down below and that
my friends is episode 43 I know there's
any comments of like I know there's me a
lot of happy anniversary happy birthday
I know there's me like too fast Gary
like I like the longer shows this is not
I know but I don't have the time today
but we still pumped it out I'm gonna
miss you I'll be back Tuesday we'll do
it then question a day there is none
just give me some love oh crap wait
subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe